[Musica]
[Applauso]
greca
l'orso polare il cibo bio di alluvioni
l'amazzonia la plastica il riciclo il
monopattino l'eolico gli incendi ma
insomma io non sono un'esperta di
sostenibilità certo tengo all'ambiente
ma cosa posso fare ancora vado in
bicicletta uso poco la macchina riciclo
differenzia i rifiuti sono vegetariana
ma quanto ho compreso questa sera non
basta quando penso al cambiamento
climatico
mi sento molto confusa all'incirca così
succede succede anche a voi sono giulia
sono una formatrice è una consulente ma
soprattutto sono un abitante del pianeta
terra e questa sera voglio capirci di
più
l'abbiamo appena sentito il problema è
grave le informazioni sono tantissimi
arrivano da fonti diverse a volte anche
contrastanti e non è per niente facile
capire che cosa fare e come muoversi
l'inventore del ted saul wurman ha
identificato questa situazione questa
nostra condizione e la chiamata
information anxiety ansia da
informazione che quello stato quella
condizione che ci prende quando
tantissime informazioni una marea
montante di dati ogni giorno ci assale
portandoci in una situazione quasi di
paralisi
mentale pensate che le informazioni
contenute in un solo quotidiano quello
che troviamo in edicola sono pari alla
totalità delle informazioni che una
persona media all'epoca di shakespeare
apprendeva in tutta la vita si vero son
passati 400 anni anche di più ma in
questo breve lasso di tempo il nostro
cervello non è evoluto per affrontare
questa mole di dati e allora che cosa
possiamo fare io ho trovato un sistema
per comprendere meglio il cambiamento
climatico ma anche per ragionare in modo
ordinato e creativo e questa sera voglio
proporvelo portarvelo e sono le mappe
mentali
le mappe mentali sono uno strumento di
visualizzazione del pensiero e ci
aiutano a organizzare i dati a
memorizzare ciò che leggiamo e avere
degli stimoli creativi per trovare nuove
soluzioni
qualcuno di voi forse le conosce perché
sono state inventate
già negli anni settanta da un
professionista uno psicologo inglese
tony buzan mio maestro e mentore
eccolo qua e adesso sempre di più stanno
diventando uno strumento proprio per
abbassare questa situazione di stress e
combattere l'inquinamento informativo
provo a raccontarvi un po come
funzionano
selezioniamo le informazioni le
riduciamo le sintetizziamo e le
inseriamo in una struttura che è molto
simile a come tutto si sviluppa in
natura gli alberi
i fiori i fiumi e questa struttura poi
riproduce anche fisiologicamente proprio
i nostri pensieri sia dal punto di vista
funzionale che dal punto di vista fisico
la nostra rete neurale
quindi partiamo da un concetto che è un
nucleo dal quale poi si irradiano
associazioni e connessioni fino ad altri
concetti arrivando all'infinito in
questo modo troviamo riusciamo a
strutturare una mole di informazioni in
maniera sintetica ottenendo chiarezza
ordine gerarchia e facendo spazio a
nuove idee
infatti noi siamo qui per questo siamo
qui per trovare delle soluzioni nuove
delle nuove idee per il cambiamento
climatico ma questa che cos'è che ci può
stimolare la creatività cos'è che può
accelerare i nostri processi cognitivi
vi chiedo un po di collaborazione quando
prima salendo sul palco ho pronunciato
la parola greta cosa è successo nella
vostra mente qualcuno di voi ha visto
questo no di sicuro il vostro cervello
in un nanosecondo ha ricostruito il
ricordo di quella ragazzina svedese con
il viso un po corrucciato e magari avete
visto anche il suo impermeabile giallo e
il cartello dello sciopero qualcosa di
questo tipo
ecco il nostro cervello lavora con le
immagini le immagini sono il linguaggio
primitivo immediato universale della
nostra mente
ma dove sono le immagini nei nostri
lavori nei nostri documenti nelle nostre
email
se noi riusciamo ad esprimerci con un
disegno riusciamo ad aiutare e ad
aumentare proprio quella sintesi che ci
richiede la famosa information ansa.it e
quindi sviluppare la nostra creatività
vedo le vostre facce e provo a leggere
nella vostra mente obiezione ma noi non
sappiamo disegnare giusto obiezione
respinta
mi dispiace non è che non sapete di
segnare e che avete smesso come me
quando avevate 78 anni quasi tutti qui
in sala e anche a casa perché c'erano
materie più importanti giustamente da
apprendere ma la buona notizia è che il
cervello e plastico si comporta
esattamente come un muscolo e quindi se
noi ci alleniamo o alleniamo da zero
questa competenza siamo in grado di
accelerare i nostri processi cognitivi e
stimolare ancora una volta la creatività
un'altra buona abitudine che abbiamo
perso e l'utilizzo dei colori
anche qui lasciata da piccoli a scuola
immaginate di girare londra con una
mappa della metropolitana di questo tipo
anche in questo caso mi dispiace dirvelo
ma arriverete in ritardo al vostro
appuntamento da studi universitari i
colori aumentano la comprensione e la
memorizzazione del 90 per cento e quindi
perché non utilizzarli di nuovo nei
nostri seri lavori e documenti
siamo arrivati a identificare quelli che
sono i tre pilastri delle mappe mentali
una struttura chiara e ordinata
le immagini che ci danno la possibilità
di velocizzare il nostro cervello ai
colori che stimolano la nostra
creatività e la capacità di essere
innovativi questo strumento è tanto
potente quanto semplice chiaro davvero
facile da utilizzare
ma il countdown è partito lo sappiamo e
siamo qui proprio per re immaginare una
nuova mappa che ci porta in una
direzione diversa
e allora questa sera vi ho portato tre
esempi tre sfide da iniziare da subito
da domani con un foglio bianco e qualche
pennarello colorato la prima corrisponde
all'obiettivo di selezionare le
informazioni che ritenete più importanti
e memorizzarle vi piacerebbe allora
domani vi invito a prendere un foglio a
mettere il logo del tedax al centro e
disegnare 9 rami uno per ogni speaker
fermando quelle informazioni che più vi
hanno colpito che ritenete utili in modo
da trasformare un informazione in
piccoli atti di valore e di cambiamento
il secondo obiettivo risponde proprio
all'idea di fermarci a pensare cosa che
non facciamo quasi mai fermarci a
pensare a i temi che il ted ci ha
proposto durante questa iniziativa del
countdown l'energia il trasporto i
materiali il cibo la natura e io vi
aggiunto noi noi stessi perché abbiamo
sentito più volte oggi che il vero
cambiamento parte
dal cambiamento nostro quindi qui
possiamo andare a posizionare delle
piccole azioni sui vari rami nelle varie
aree che ci permettano di cambiare stile
di vita di fare qualcosa per partecipare
a questo cambiamento
l'ultima sfida è sicuramente la più
impattante e la più impegnativa e vela
lancio così vogliamo creare una visione
una visione al 2030 tra dieci anni
quando il countdown arriverà a zero dove
volete essere con chi volete vivere dove
volete stare qua la qualità del cibo
dell'area del vostro della vostra
famiglia delle vostre relazioni
ecco sicuramente sarà una visione bella
ed appagante
allora dovete partire da quella visione
e disegnare a ritroso le tappe che vi
portano fino alla per dare il vostro
vero contributo a questo countdown a
questa trasformazione
l'ultima mappa che voglio mostrarvi non
l'ho disegnata io l'ha disegnata un
ragazzino di 13 anni che si chiama raimi
raimi aveva grosse difficoltà nello
studio e nell'esprimersi davanti agli
altri quasi aveva deciso di non voler
andare più a scuola
quest'estate abbiamo lavorato insieme e
la sua ricerca e la sua mappa gli hanno
fatto da lascia passare dalla seconda
alla terza media ha raccontato il suo
periodo di lock down quando con i suoi
genitori ha imparato ad autoprodursi il
cibo e l'energia elettrica ci sono nella
sua mappa alimentazione consumi
paesi virtuosi ma la cosa che colpisce
di più è quello che lui dice di avere
imparato ad essere indipendente ed auto
prodursi cibo ed energia elettrica per
affrontare quello che la sfida che pensa
di dover vedere nel suo futuro
[Applauso]
vi garantisco che raimi ha vinto sulle
sue paure e ha preso una lezione che
sarà importantissima per la sua vita
noi abbiamo una sfida da vincere
nei prossimi 10 anni che è quella di
restituire a remi ea tutti gli adulti
del 2030 un paese in europa è un pianeta
degni di essere chiamati casa
[Applauso]